they had a very similar situation and went
to look you know to make a pass that's the
difference between a a guy who's struggling
to score goals and one who's not ericon e
tried to go short side against monmo knock in
right over the shoulder here Eric picking up a
loose Puck short side roof that top area is not
completely sealed there and that just catches
the top of the right shoulder of monteno Baldi
for ericon X to Baldi in the corner sweeps it
around for Rossi Rossi comes off the boards
with it pressured by kevic Capri across Bing
scores Montreal Canadians just way too aggressive
up at the top of the zone and they pay for those
for that mistake up at the top that's when you've
got the opposition out of position like that it's
all about getting to the paint making plays as
quick as you possibly can caprisa Suzuki plays
it out to the line Baron around behind the net
maroon over to pick it up for Minnesota he gave
it away Suzuki denied by gustofson you could see
that he just he wasn't ready there and he went
down there worked on his skating and he just looks
like a completely different player the PRI kicked
it into the slot Rossy had another chance but
was tied up by [Applause] mat now Rossy needed
a point he was passed in the rookie scoring Race
by Adam fanelly of Columbus now with that point
he moves back into a tie for second among firste
players here's Rossy again he [Music] scores it's
a two-point night for the rookie and it's 20-0
Minnesota [Music] this is the play I just got
back outside the blue line to keep that on side
and B Goan with a great feed through about three
sticks to the far side of the rink hits Marco
Rossi right on the tape look at the Nifty pass
by the big man and that puck just rolls up on edge
and beats monteo on the far side just like look at
the puck is not completely over the line now it
is but it's you know his skate can be inside the
zone right now it almost looks like simultaneous
doesn't it yeah is it enough to overturn it guys
like you mentioned it's the call in the ice is
a goal so it has to be Tai goes to the runner
kg I thought right let's take that time I I I
can't see how this is overturned I I haven't
seen enough evidence on yeah I think if the
call had gone the other way i' say the same
thing after the coaches challenges determined
that the play was on side we have a good goal
so the goal stands and it's two Z into the
middle gagoski goodro back to gagoski goodro
looking down low Felino tried to flip one
short side montmo got a shoulder on it the
Canadians clear L Terry's back on the Wilder
at full strength and still leading by two gson
slides across glove save rebound loose they score
saard Beats gustaffson from the top of the circle
and the Canadians cut the lead to two to one well
the Wild player that was in The Penalty Box entry
here nice little give and go Coffield tries short
side there and then tries to wrap the puck around
went right off the end of his stick and went
right to card on the backside who scores his
second goal of the year the Montreal Canadians
percentage wise what a great little look there
and a great shot up to The Far Side this is
Coffield trying to stuff it went right to the
defenseman card but the m Canadian Energy power
play fourth chance for Minnesota one for three
Tonight Eric s capris off out front Johansson
pad save monmo down to 22 in the power play
as Faber back pedals Baldi to capriso down
low Erikson at fire save monmo and he hangs
on mat centers
slavoski to mat back to slavoski a shot
tip rebound they score Suzuki ties it for
Montreal a power play goal for the Canadians
as the Canadians tie it yeah this this shot
on net that headed toward guson looked to me
like a caught Jake Middleton with an open hand
there that's a dangerous play hope he's okay but
that puck loose Puck pops out to Suzuki the the
Montreal Canadians leading scorer scores his ninth
goal of this season this is the play right here
you want to turn your hand the other way if you're
a penalty killer he just it's so easy to break
fingers when you Middleton takes a look loses slab
kovski spins it down a low to Baldi Baldi out of
the corner Works to the slot a shot off the post I
thought he was going to shoot it right here takes
an extra second to give himself a better angle
again Marco Rossy right around the paint that
one right off the post does not beat the post
and the wild with their FP power play of the
night fav Bo to the middle
[Music] [Applause] score the man does it all
of his career probably his first Power Play
goal in about seven years since he played the
development team there again I mentioned this
during the first period I love that he is willing
to shoot the puck from the top and not defer to
guys on the side getting pucks to that when you
got a guy like U Eric an Eck out in front of the
net broken stick at the line allows Johansson a
chance he gives to Felino Felino for rosi rosi
fired P save rebound Felino pushed it just wide
in case Freddy gets Dro thrown out or any other
Center for that matter mat able to hold his own
Coffield carries down low saard fire save Guston a
rebound they score slavski deflected the puck that
seemed to make it too tough for Guston to seal on
the rebound and the Canadians have tied it with
303 left teams in the faceoff Circle get the puck
from low to high slapovi deflects this Puck then
ends up going off Jake Middleton here's the shot
here from svar from the back end hits the big slow
back right there then right off of the shin pad of
Jake Middleton and he's unable to get a stick on
that before it goes over the line in the mtal for
the so all even with two and A2 to go Baldi
has it for Eric s fires and a glove save by
montmo great backhand look Eric sck was able
to take that off his skate and monteno favor
fires just wide long rebound manth hustling
after it two onone with Coffield man fir save
Guston rebound Caufield knocked it on net and
Guston snatches it with a glove favor capriso
in with speed capriso swings wide triy to Center
bounces to Johansson Johansson centers capric
go [Music] unbelievable the thrill does
it again and the Wild win it four three in
overtime Krill capriso on the back door what a
play there by Marcus Johansson 30 foot saucer
Krill capriso is able to just slip away that puck
lands right on his stick and he does what he does
and that score overtime goals that's his eighth
in the Minnesota Wild uniform watch how he just
slicks slickly moves to the backside what a pass
by Joe Hanson and the Russian makes no mistake